hello and welcome
foreign
today we're presenting a program preview
of the professional certificate program
in data analytics
my name is Stuart Creek
I'm a marketing manager here at simply
learn the delivery partner with
Purdue University for this program
also in collaboration with IBM
and
we're going to be hearing a little bit
today from Brian Campbell who is a very
experienced program in project
management expert but also an analytics
expert he's going to be talking about
um
the program he is the president of Seven
Seas Consulting he's one of our senior
instructors and our simpler simply
learned programs so we'll hear from him
in a bit
and
we're going to be covering what data
analytic career opportunities that are
out there for you
and then what this program offers how it
gets you job ready
the enrollment steps that you need to
take if you're interested and I'll cover
some of your questions toward the end of
the
webinar
the going to begin with
a segment that
Brian recorded
I will
play that for you in just a moment
and he'll be talking about careers and
data analytics
foreign
so let's talk a bit about data analytics
careers can sound like something might
be in this space you're interested in
getting in the space movie just you know
spent a few years recently graduated
from college or even doing this for a
while and you see the opportunity here
so let's talk a bit about how important
data is through our new digital economy
so I'm sure you can all appreciate
companies are basing their decisions
based on the data that they have the
struggle of course there's so much data
it's difficult to interpret and they
need people data analysts who can help
them get the insights they need to make
the right business decisions
and just to put this a little bit in
perspective of the volume of data that
is being collected and captured has just
grown exponentially over the last 20
years and you can see this number here
175 zettabytes of data by 2025 and if
you're not terribly familiar with the
xenobite is it's about 7.5 trillion MP3
results
that's a single
that abides so that's 175 of those and
it's going to continue to grow so
there's a lot of interest in
organizations to get help analyzing
interpreting and using this data so they
can determine the best products they can
bring to Market or ensure that they're
getting the best customer experience to
their customers and in fact the fortune
which is one of the leading business
analytical magazines and organizations
forecasted Big Data spending is going to
grow from 41 million dollars in 2019.
to 116 billion dollars in 2027. so
organizations see the value and the
importance of this and making some big
investments in this space
and as a result the demand for data
analysts is skyrocketing we can see here
that about 23 growth
data analytics jobs are 2026 so it's
coming up very quickly we just stepped
into a 2022 here and 11.5 million new
jobs
so there's lots of opportunity and see
the organizations that are hiring the
companies were all globally familiar
with Amazon Facebook uh JPMorgan Chase
in a big Global Banking and Financial
Services organizations all of them are
leveraging this data Apple of course
Microsoft Google they're all driving the
demand for these kinds of rules
so what do you really need in expert
data analysts well this is kind of
important because this is the area you
want to go into you should probably be
familiar with what it's going to look
like versus you're going to need to have
some interest familiarity and and skills
with statistics
you need to be able to extract
from all that data that an organization
has and determine some statistics what
kind of you know growth are they singers
what percentage growth compared to past
periods
what's the absolute numbers the relative
numbers uh giving them this ability to
how this data can help them make good
decisions do this you're going to need
some programming skills and most of
these are in this data extraction and
cleansing and normalizes and integrated
to the point that you can visualize it
put it into bar graphs or line charts or
any numbers of different ways in which
we can visualize that information so
organizations can make effective
decisions
creating models so you can pull data in
and use that those models determine
things like customer satisfaction or
market growth and in the classification
methods organizations
you know what kind of customers do we
have what are some of the age brackets
we want to focus on what what are some
of the the demand that we're seeing
different genders or geographies
and then of course artificial
intelligence is becoming more and more
prominent so finding ways to get this
data to shift this into artificial
intelligence platforms so they can make
decisions and I'm sure most of you have
probably had some experiences when you
go to websites and you want to interact
with your customer support and you click
on that chat button
typically the first types of responses
you get from that chat bot is from an
artificial intelligent agent that is
being fed by all the data that has been
gathered from from previous interactions
with customers so these are real
opportunities for organizations not just
to provide more products and services
but increase their customer support
and
what I'm going to do now is share with
you a poll
to ask you about
what's prevented you up until now from
becoming
data analytics expert
and I'd like you to answer in the WebEx
poll widget here
will stay open for another 10 seconds
get your answers in please
I'm about to close the poll
all right
so about half of our audience
thinks that they haven't found a program
that can give them practical experience
that they can demonstrate
to potential employers
then anywhere from 10 to a quarter of
the audience as the
other issues with programs they've seen
so let's go into
this particular program
it's a program from Purdue University
it's delivered by simply learn it's the
professional certificate program in data
analytics
and
it is a comprehensive program it's
delivered entirely online
it takes you about eight months to
complete
and your obligation is to devote about
10 hours a week
through the course
that covers both the live virtual
classes that you'll take
over the weekends or sometimes
weeknights
and that's eight hours of instruction a
week
um and then you have your projects and
homework that you do anytime in between
on the online platform so you can fit
that to whatever days and hours
fit into your schedule and are
convenient for you
and
it includes integrated case studies
integrated projects things that you do
that give you practical hands-on
experience with tools Concepts platforms
for data analytics so that you build up
a portfolio of projects that you can
then show too
a potential employer
so this is
what the program
offers you at the end of the process
you'll receive
a certificate from
Purdue University and simply learn that
certifies that you've completed the
program successfully all the core
courses
along the way if you take the courses
from IBM
a couple of the core courses come from
IBM and IBM will issue you a certificate
that is independent of the program that
you can then also show off to employers
you'll have over 14 Hands-On projects
and integrated Labs along the way so
you'll be building up that portfolio of
project
and you'll be able to take master
classes
from Purdue University instructors and
from IBM industry instructors
um IBM also offers as part of the
program hackathons and AMA sessions
so you get exposure to
those folks from industry and then we'll
talk more about the Capstone project
which is
how you demonstrate at the end of the
program that you have
added all of these skills to your
portfolio to your personal toolkit and
that you're able
to use them
and in an integrated project that solves
an industry or business align problem
and
part of the program also is oriented
toward your career we offer job assist
to those users who are in
India or in the United States
virtually not in other countries but all
everyone gets a Purdue alumni
association membership so they can do
networking with other folks from Purdue
you know other
students who have graduated or completed
programs like this
so
moving forward
a little bit about Purdue University
what makes it special
Purdue University is a 151 year old
institution is
one of the first land-grant universities
in the United States meaning it was set
up
buy a special
active
the government of the state of Indiana
and it is consistently one of the top
public universities
in the United States
one of the top universities in the world
it has produced Nobel Prize winners
among its graduates and
having Purdue University on your CV is
definitely a prestigious accomplishment
it's something that people will
recognize worldwide the name Purdue
University
does have that pull
so this is something that will add value
to your resume just from the name but
also from the quality of the education
you also have the advantage of IBM and
IBM offers
courses but it also offers as I
mentioned master classes and
hackathons and ask me anything sessions
that enhance the program for you and
give you a chance to further develop
your skills get more insights into the
industry and the career field so this is
a we're really very proud of this part
of our program and our partnership with
IBM
as I mentioned simply learn offers
career assist service
and
this is
provided through two of our partners in
India it's IIM jobs and in
the United States it's Talent Inc
um that's part of the service and I will
talk about that in a moment
we also offer access to career webinars
expert webinars and different technology
topics
industry Outlook webinars
these are all free and available to you
and
you also have your portfolio of projects
that you've developed in the program
as a job search tool
let's talk about the job assist services
directly provided by our partners so
one of them is the job portal resume
rabbit in the U.S IIM jobs in India
and this gives you access to their
exclusive sets of job opportunities
um
this gives you the ability to search
those opportunities
uh
apply to them without revealing anything
to your current employer the discretion
is very important privacy is very
important
but the other two parts of the service I
think in my opinion are more important
resume review and rewrite service from
the
Talent Inc version is called top resume
both in India and in the US resume
review and rewrite is so important
because today
your resume will not hit the desk of a
human being until it's passed through an
automated tracking system which includes
an AI bot that will evaluate your resume
against the job description
and understanding how to create and
craft a resume so that it has the
highest chance of passing through the AI
review on the one hand but also is still
attractive and
catches the attention of the human
on the other end of the process is
almost an art form and so having the
help of professional resume writers at
this stage in the
job search is very important
um
you also get one-on-one interview
practice services including some career
coaching and
the interviews allow you to practice
both the subject matter types of
interviews that you'll do in technical
questions about data analytics but they
also allow you to practice the
interviews
that are for softer skills and for team
players and the types of questions
managers will ask about how well you'll
fit in with the organization so those
types of interviews you'll end up with
both types when you go out for your job
search and it's important to know how to
Ace both kinds of interviews so this is
a again a very valuable aspect
now these Services extend for six months
after you completed the program so you
have the eight months of doing the
program where you can start using some
of these services and then or six months
after you receive your certificate
you have access to these services
this is uh to help you
look for and find that next job it is
not a job placement it is a job search
assistance program
I mentioned the expert webinars we do
webinars on a continual basis several a
week many of these uh webinars are
with experts in Industry talking about
what you need to know to get a career in
a particular area or how to get the most
out of your job search
um
introduce people to new
technology areas like blockchain we talk
about
um
mini lessons one hour lessons
technology topics so all of these are
free and all of them are available to
you
on going into the future so there's no
time limit on this
let's talk about the eligibility and
prerequisites that you must have and
that you should have
to be able to join this program
there is one prerequisite that you must
have which is a bachelor's degree can be
in any discipline it does not have to be
a technology or mathematics statistics
or computer programming computer science
degree
um but you do have to have 50 or higher
marks which is a GPA of 2.0 or above
then you can come from a programming or
a non-programming background
data analytics is a technical field
um it requires an understanding of
statistics and some
uh aspects of programming but we will
teach you those things so if you come in
without those
in your background you'll have access to
the materials you'll need to get a good
grounding in those topics so that you
can succeed in the program
uh it's good to have work experience for
this program it is not mandatory but we
we say that it's always good to have at
least two years of work experience
um so we will be asking that question
when you apply to the program but again
work experience is not mandatory you can
come straight out of
your education out of your formal
education to this program
so having said all that I'd like to get
a feeling from the audience of
uh
how much experience you do have
it's going to ask this poll question
gives me a feeling for
who's attending today what your what
your particular concerns and needs are
we'll leave this open another 10 seconds
here
okay
and I'm going to close the pole
so about a little under half of the
audience are people with less than two
years of experience Maybe
still students are coming straight out
of school
or just new in the workforce
um
the rest of our audience has
a range of experience from two years on
up to more than 10 years
program is designed to work for both
the people without experience and the
people with extensive experience
anywhere you fall on the Spectrum you
can succeed in this program very well
move on
we'll talk about how that works and I'm
going to let Brian
get in a recorded segment
take you on a live tour of the learning
environment and
how that works for you so let me set
that up
we'll get that started
okay so now we're going to shift gears a
little bit and let's take a look at what
this learning environment uh consists of
so bear with me here as I bring that up
so this is often virtually with the
learning management system that simply
learn has been the best again over many
many years and you'll see it's got a
really nice layout it's very accessible
you can tell that they've been applying
some of their their uh
design uh development skills and UI
development skills so it's really easy
to navigate you'll see there's a big
button that says go to program for the
postgraduate program data analytics it's
going to bring you to the courses that
you have
now this is uh one of the upcoming
courses and um gives you a little flavor
of what you can inspect of course
there'll be a welcome class that's real
times you get a chance to get exposed to
that we've got a collection of different
courses here uh data analytics we've got
programming with python our programming
data science Tableau and then of course
our Capstone program and dive into one
of these there's a little bit more depth
uh you've got both live classes self
learning and labs
let's click on the self learning
and you'll see that we've got a
collection of different topics you can
click
and click key and it's a nice sort of
video LED format as you progress through
the content you've got knowledge checks
you can apply kind of assess if you
captured all the important information
there's practice lab so you can click on
practice labs to be up to kind of again
find these these hand on Hands-On skills
there's also live classes these haven't
been scheduled yet because the program
hasn't started but when they do you'll
have the ability to kind of join in with
live classes that are available but
directed and facilitated by people like
myself there's assessments you can take
quizzes that kind of help you validate
you've learned the concepts and then
finally certificates that you can unlock
once you've completed your training
so uh really You Know Rich and and
content filled learning management
system that gives you lots of
flexibility a lot of it is already on
self-paced learning so you've got the
flexibility to kind of take that
learning when it's convenient to you it
could be during your lunch hours it
could be in the evenings the weekends as
well as instructor land so you get an
opportunity to kind of ask questions
directly to an instructor to hear this
these concerts explained and then
there's also this uh this community that
is I think one of the more powerful
parts of the program is you click on
community brings up pull a list of
different topic areas you can spend time
with your your peers and colleagues ask
questions partner together on projects
and lab assignments anything that you
need to get help on
I wanted to spend a little bit of time
just giving a bit of flavor on that this
is accessible through any kind of device
a lot of people like to use it on their
cell phones and tablets these days so
mobile but whether you're have a laptop
or a PC a tablet even a phone you'll be
able to access all this great
information
foreign
and we'll go back to
the rest of our presentation here
so Brian showed you the integrated
learning environment
and I'm going to talk to you a bit about
the program curriculum
so the program curriculum is built to
give you a set of skills that builds up
in a stepwise fashion
startup was an orientation session of
course that goes through what to expect
from the program what
additional
foundational material you might want to
study based on your particular
background how to use the learning
management system the brand just showed
you all of that type of thing
and once you've completed that you
unlock the first course the analytics
Foundation course analytics Foundation
gives you an overview of what analytics
is basic understanding of
what's necessary in terms of statistical
Concepts
it gives you the the
base of knowledge that you need then
move on to the next course which is the
programming foundation and data
analytics so you're learning Python
Programming in that course and again if
you come in without a programming
background during the orientation period
between the orientation and the
beginning of analytics Foundation
you'll be given access to courses that
will get you
um
Basics you need so that you can succeed
in the Python Programming module
once you've gotten through Python
Programming you introduce the language R
which is designed for data analysis data
science and so you get taken through uh
basics of our programming and then into
data science with our applying R to data
science problems
um
the next course is Tableau training
because you understand the tools for
visualization of data and there's
analytics results
and finally as I mentioned before the
Capstone project
which takes all of these skills
ask you to apply them together in an
integrated project to solve a industrial
line
problem
now you notice we talk about data
science and that's and along with data
analytics and you know I saw a question
that one wanted to understand the
difference between data science and data
but data science is the fundamental
principles of
how to extract information from data
so it covers all of the tools and
modeling and all of the theory behind
what patterns you can find in data
data analytics applies that to
particular problems so the data
scientist will look at
General data set and say okay these are
different ways to extract information
based on what you want to find out from
the this data set here are different
models and algorithms that can be used
when
the data science scientist has completed
that work they passed that on to the
analytics team and the analytics team
now has a tool set
where they can
apply those models and algorithms to
specific problems so if there's a
general principle of how do we figure
out what the seasonal variation in our
sales is
you have the data science
team the data scientists who look at
that data and come up with ways to
extract that information
then the data analytics team on an
ongoing basis will look the information
that's coming in each quarter or each
month or each week and pull that into
the models create the
ultimate information reports for
management so
data analytics the applied version of
data science
along the way in the program
you get to take electives at your
discretion they are at no additional
cost
and you can take as many as you feel you
have the time and the inclination to
take
power bi is another
analysis tool from Microsoft
um
introduction to artificial intelligence
which gives you a little bit of exposure
to some of the
more advanced and
more interesting topics that are going
to affect the analytics in the future
um you can take master classes from the
Purdue University
instructors and you can also
take master classes from IBM Personnel
all of those things are available to you
as well
and
along the way you'll Master the various
tools libraries and platforms that data
analysts use
um
you have a number of them listed here we
mentioned Python and R power bi also
Excel on Tableau different
libraries for python like numpy and
sci-fi for an analysis of
numerical and scientific problems so
you'll not only be exposed to these and
learn what they are but you'll also ask
to use them in your projects
so at the end of the process
you'll be able to say with confidence
that not only am I
familiar with Priceline for example but
I've used it in these projects only am I
familiar with Tableau but here's how I
used it in these projects and you can
take a look at my portfolio that's a
very powerful
tool that you have going into your job
search after the program
the Capstone project which I've
mentioned a few times
takes all of those tools platforms and
all the skills you learned about using
them and all the knowledge you gained
about the principles of data science
techniques of programming to do data
analysis and it asks you to put that all
together
to solve
industry aligned problem
so you'll be able to choose from several
different domains for example a
financial industry problem or consumer
products type problem and that it will
be stated as
this company needs to find out this
information
from this data how would you do that so
you build the actual solution program it
you run it on the databases that have
been put together for this purpose and
demonstrate that your product Your
solution works this is about a three to
four week process and you do it under
the mentorship of one of your
instructors where you meet with them
weekly and go over your progress and
they help make sure that you're not
going down any dead ends or reaching any
blockers or doubts that would prevent
you from completing
um and at the end of the process you
submit the project which is basically on
your final exam for the program
you have to succeed in the Capstone
project in order to earn your
certificate
and once you do you have this as a tool
in your portfolio again you can show off
to a potential employer
this is the problem they asked me to
solve this is how I solved it this is my
solution and this is how it works and
that gives you the ability then to say
you gave me a problem like this in
employee
you can have the confidence that I'd be
able to solve it
this is really one of the I think the
most valuable pieces of this program
our program advisors include
Dr Wolf from the Purdue University
and Ronald Van Loon who is
um
industry expert in data science
these people helped design the courses
the curriculum and oversee the delivery
so they make sure that the program meets
the requirements
uh that Purdue University has set forth
with these
this type of education though
here's a testimonial from a past learner
and I'll give you a moment to read that
but basically uh sahaja is saying that
this is an area that
really interests him
invites him and
coming in from a background without data
science understanding or without coding
experience he's
delighted that he was able to then
learn the concepts succeed in this
and um
come out of it
with the certification that helped his
career so
this is the type of result that
like to see from our learners
at this point I'm going to ask about
enrollment steps
so first are you interested based on
what you've heard so far
in enrolling in this program
I asked this whole question
any moment
and I'll share with you the enrollment
steps the schedule the program costs in
just a moment so
all right
and we'll close the poll in just a
couple of seconds
to get your answers in and I'm going to
close the poll now
so you can see about 90 of our audience
a little over ninety percent of our
audience are uh interested in enrolling
definitely or maybe so I'm going to
share with you
the steps and the other details here
the enrollment process is very
straightforward
normal process enrollment process is
email us at ask us at simplylearn.net
and when you do
you'll be in contact with our
learning Consultants
they'll be able to take you through the
enrollment process you'll need to submit
some information about yourself in order
to complete the enrollment process
including your academic qualifications
proof that you have your bachelor's
degree you'll need to um
take an evaluation of your
abilities and programming statistics
things like that so that we know what
additional support you'll need coming
into the program and you don't have to
have any background in those areas it's
just the assessment test that allows us
to help you succeed and
presuming you've passed all the
requirements then you get an admission
offer by email I just put the email
address into the chat for everyone so
um
the next cohort
and practically get into is uh an
orientation starts on a January the
classes themselves start on 20 January
in uh North American time that happens
to be 21st January morning
India so
um
that's the beginning of the next cohort
the pricing here is shown in both US
dollars and Indian rupees and
if you are in India the price will be
denominated in rupees see that
um two lock twelve thousand four hundred
and fifteen
and you can Finance it for as low as uh
7051 per month that's zero interest
financing
for people in the U.S or anywhere else
in the rest of the world
denominated in installers so that's
three thousand seven hundred forty nine
dollars for the program which can be
financed at 3 30 a month
so again
reach out to us and ask us at
simplylearn.net
will be able to get the enrollment
process started
um
just another quick question for you in
the audience
if you are part of the 90 who are
interested in
I think that this is something you want
to do when do you want to do it you want
to get into that January cohort
um do you maybe want to do the one right
after that or are you looking
uh further out
again we always say that if something
that's going to improve your life in
your career
um consider doing it sooner than later
here we go
all right
and about a third of our audience wants
to get started either in the January
cohort or the ones right after that so
um again
email us at ask us simplylearned.net get
that process started for you
so I've been watching and I've seen a
number of questions coming in
this is the time where I'm going to try
to answer those for you
and
there you go
so I'm going to scroll through the chat
to find the questions but we do have
foreign
looking through the chat here
we already talked
Camilla Rossi asked about the difference
between data scientists and data
analysts that talked about the two roles
uh
the users asked about a career Gap can
you join the data analytics program
after a career Gap and the answer is yes
you can
you do need to have the bachelor's
degree do you need to have the other
qualifications
um
they're
your career Gap is not a factor in
joining this program
um
and this program may be helpful to you
to get past the career Gap and
demonstrate that you have a new skill
set to offer in the market so that's
good
um
already talked about the fees I'm going
through here
okay
can your bachelor's degree be math
Mathias sorry ask if bachelor's degree
can be from Brazil yeses if it's an
accredited Institution
your bachelor's degree can be
from Brazil or any other country
looking up here
one moment
venkatesh asks a question
are they providing projects to keep in
resume
so IAM jobs isn't doing that
you do that through the program you can
also do that through things like uh
hacker rank or other companies that will
offer uh open source projects or other
hackathons that you
develop projects that you can add to
your portfolios
and John asked what if I have three
years of my
diploma do you need to have a bachelor's
degree awarded it has to be
if you're in your final year of
University or college you can
um
enroll in the program so long as your
bachelor's degree will be awarded before
you complete this partner
and
see if we have another question
hold on just a second
all right Christian has to ask a
question about comparing this to some of
the free courses simply and offers for
skills like Python and other courses and
the some of the fundamentals if you came
in without a programming background
this program and needed to have
um
some basic grounding and programming as
part of the preparation we would refer
you to some of our free courses on
basics of programming but when you get
into the python course
we're offering a program that's designed
uh with IBM so it's not at all the same
as the free course that we offer for
reviewing python offer those free
courses as a basic service those are all
self-directed video courses
um
and
this is an entirely different program
so
do we have a
the answer to your question is yes this
is a much more intensive program
Eric lay asks do you have a program for
data scientists if you work and find
them so if you go to our website
um I'm going to give you right now the
link to
the home page for this program that
you'll be able to also navigate
take a look at some of the other
programs that we have you'll be able to
look in the
data science category for example or any
of the other technology categories that
we have
and just put that into the chat and you
can take a look at the different
programs that we have we have a similar
program from Purdue for example there's
a professional certification
professional certificate program excuse
me in data science so
uh you have the option of doing it
covers some of the same material and
then goes into more depth in certain
other topics as well
and
I think that covers all of the questions
that have come in so far let me see
yeah
uh last question I'll take
tabish s
yracuse Bachelor of Commerce
The Bachelor of Commerce through this
program yes you can if you have a
bachelor's degree from an accredited
institution and if you earn 50 marks or
better
uh absolutely
you qualified for this program
if this is something that is of interest
to you and if you're really
motivated to use data analytics
uh your career
and
should I asked one more question which
is
um
we have other programs Masters in data
science masters and business analysis
that type of thing
um those are not affiliated with the
universities the way this one is so
um the there's an advantage in this
program of the
participation of Purdue University and
the quality of their master classes and
that type of thing so those those ads
different kind of value to this program
compared to the other one
um
I think that covers it asks uh don't
have a bachelor's what do you what do I
suggest if you don't have your
bachelor's currently or not working on a
bachelor's we do have other programs
that are available uh
which I pointed out the master's program
may may be appropriate it may not have
the same requirement
um and for the bachelor's degree there
are other other courses that we offer
and there are other avenues for getting
some basic studies of
data analytics so
you can actually contact our learning
consultants and they can advise you on
that as well
uh
Victor Fernandez will the instructors be
native English speakers the English is a
second language I would contact our
learning instructors about that concern
um
some of our instructors for this program
are
folks who work in India the the they
speak perfectly good English
if you have a difficulty with accented
English
um that may be issue but we have other
programs that are offered uh with uh
U.S based instructors
and so you may want to find out about
those as well
and
uh
Eric asks
if Learners spend more hours a week
possible to finish the program in less
than eight months
generally speaking it really
isn't because we want to make sure that
you follow the curriculum in a
completely and part of the instruction
is
through live virtual classes that are on
a weekly schedule
so you won't be able to skip ahead of
the live classes for each course and
then you won't be able to skip ahead to
feature courses until you complete the
one you're in so
um this is really gen
designed to be followed in a
particular schedule
um
but again you can ask the
learning consultants if they have more
advice for you on that with that I'm
going to close the
question period
I want to thank everybody for the
questions I apologize if I haven't
gotten to yours
and
we'll move on
to the
if you are interested in enrolling if
this is something that you're interested
in doing
um like to ask
do you need any assistance with
enrollment
ask this question
it's pretty straightforward
again for those of you who are
interested
uh more than half
again for assistance please email us at
ask us at simplylearn.net
the QR code on the screen will take you
to the program page and you can also
reach our learning Consultants through
that
with that we've reached the end of our
presentation I want to thank everyone
who came out today this evening this
morning to
um
attend this presentation
we hope we can welcome you into the
Learning Community with Purdue
University and simply learn and we hope
you have a great rest of your day or
evening depending on where you are
so thank you and goodbye